Canada has a long history of leadership
in the development
of artificial intelligence
dating right back
to CIFAR’s very first program
in the 1980's.
Canada's leadership in
AI continues today
at the three
National AI Institutes created
through the Pan-Canadian AI Strategy.
Six years
into the launch of the Strategy,
we've named over 120 world-leading
researchers as Canada CIFAR AI Chairs.
In turn, they train thousands of students,
expanding Canada's
pool of AI talent every year.
As a result,
Canada is leading the world for
AI research, consistently producing more
AI-related
research publications per capita
than any G7 nation,
and tripling our research productivity
since the start of the Strategy.
But the impact of the Pan-Canadian
AI Strategy goes way
beyond research excellence.
The Strategy is delivering
significant social
and economic benefits for all of Canada.
For example,
the number of jobs in
AI has grown significantly.
More than 140,000 AI professionals
were working in Canada by 2022.
This number increased by 29%
in a single year,
which is remarkable
growth in today's economy.
And Canada
has more than doubled
the number of AI startups
since the launch of the strategy.
These are new companies
that are commercializing innovative,
AI-based products and services
to improve our lives and economy.
But it is crucial
that we get the future of AI right
and that we deploy
and regulate it responsibly.
Canada's leadership in responsible
AI development and regulation
will drive innovation
and economic productivity,
while at the same time
helping to address
some of the most challenging problems
facing humanity
through these made-in-Canada advances.
All this means
that it is truly the time
for Canada to shine.